in this video i challenged jeremy my
fresh art of film school intern to throw
every single rule that he's just learned
out the window to prove that most rules
in filmmaking are made to be broken
morning baby
see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
so as you can see i'm in new york city
i've just moved to the states to open up
a joe which is my production company
back at home in cape town but i'm
opening up another one in los angeles
not here not in 368 but that's a story
for another time
right now in new york city i find myself
with a little bit or it's it's a
pretty big dilemma you see i left
something really important back at home
in cape town
[Music]
jeremy hey what's up dude did i by any
chance leave the big insta 360 camera
there that new one that came in a box
i have no idea
[Music]
okay you found it yeah i got it it's
sitting in the room
okay i've got to make a video with this
camera
uh you're gonna have to make this video
okay
um
okay
uh let me think i'll phone you in five
minutes okay cool yeah okay
[Music]
hey dude okay so yes what you're gonna
do so i want you to go over to my
bookshelf and get a notepad that says
breaking the law and your first task as
my intern is to break every law and
cinematography that i've written in
all by using the insta360 one rs one
inch 360 camera wow that's a mouthful
but yes all by using that make me proud
while jeremy learns to unlearn
everything that he learned at film
school or like didn't learn at film
school i'm going to in the meantime show
you a montage i made when i was back in
cape town of this beast of a 360 camera
[Music]
where'd you next alex los angeles
[Music]
yeah welcome to l.a bruh sure
[Music]
okay i've just arrived in alley to
summarize because i obviously don't have
this camera i've challenged jeremy to
test that he or anyone with minimal
filmmaking experience like actual filmic
not not film school experience can make
something great with just a little bit
of effort and minimal gear
you've probably heard of a filmmaking
term known as the 180 degree rule
basically it means that the camera
should never cross the imaginary line
between subjects in a scene this can
confuse the audience which is definitely
considered wrong
can you see me seeing you
do you understand everything about the
180 degree line yeah i think so okay
cool so now with this knowledge what i
want you to do is break that rule shoot
something doesn't matter what it is just
needs to be creative cut it and then
call me and show me and let's take it
from there cool yeah i'm good we got
this don't let us down we got to make
insta360 proud but i believe in you i
can't wait to see what you've done me
neither
that gives me no hope okay
cool i think this is all i'm gonna need
can you help me film this video yeah
sure cool and everybody dances
we are going to try to recreate that
shot from rules of attraction
okay are you guys ready
shank incredible oh it should be fine
it'll like stabilize on post
yeah i think we got it
jeremy's calling
yeah
i got something to show you let's see it
i've already finished editing it put it
together
cool cool play it play play it yeah
hey
how's it going um have you seen my
sandwich
what time
i had a sandwich in the fridge with my
name on it and uh it seems to be gone
i haven't seen anything like that
cool let me know if it turns up
hey man
dude how the [ __ ] did you do that you
like it yeah bro well done thanks okay
move on to the next one cool i'll call
you back when i'm done
he's doing good lore 2 expensive looking
shots need expensive gear
in many of my previous videos i tend to
prove that you don't necessarily need
the best gear to tell your story
okay action for this second challenge
jeremy is also going to have to prove
this theory by achieving a cinematic jib
or crane shot without a jib or a crane
it's golden hour it looks incredible
and cut let's see how that looks
jeremy said he's about a call to show me
the second law being broken high
expectations
yeah hey bro uh i think i think i broke
the second rule okay
yeah erica you ready
what
dude you're killing this you think so
that looked so good okay dope dude um
this is actually working out pretty well
i'm just about to jump on a plane to san
francisco and when i get there i want to
see the third rule being broken okay
cool
okay perfect bree i'll catch you now
cheers peace
off to san fran
[Music]
so good to see you bro law three the
dolly zoom is not just used for tension
it's the type of shot where the camera
zooms opposite to its movement it's
usually used to inside fear or amplify a
character's internal realization but
jeremy is going to use this technique
not to add tension but rather to make
something look far more epic so i'm
putting this thing nice and low
there it is there's the camera
we're sitting at about 30 kilometers an
hour
[Music]
oh my god jason got so close to the car
i think that was a good take let's see
how the see how the footage
looks it's now 10 to 1 a.m
in san francisco and jeremy's calling
yes
yo dude how's san francisco
dude how's the duddy's shot let me show
you quick i'm gonna go landscape it's
upside down
okay we counter rotating our rotate
okay you ready good
looks like some james bun [ __ ] amazing
thanks dude i think that's everything i
think i think i've done all of it
all of what i think i've i've broken all
the rules but you have broken one
hundredth
of the rules but you've passed we have a
long journey ahead there jesus you're
doing good
that's that though
okay that's the wrap how do you feel
tired we're good again perfectly dude
thanks so much peace cheers
dude i think he was stoked the point
here is that as filmmakers limitations
can be the fuel to our out-the-box
thinking to our creativity and with
tools like this there is no box there's
no 16x9 frame that we are confined to
but rather an infinite canvas for your
story to be told in the most beautifully
authentic and aesthetic way possible
and yeah that's all from me this week
thank you so much to jeremy and the team
for pulling us off you guys did
incredibly and i'm blown away by your
talent then again i don't know if it's
your talent or if it's the camera you as
the audience tell me what do you think
and obviously thank you brew for
watching for commenting and for
subscribing and turning that
notifications bell on other than that
don't forget you're awesome bru and i'll
see you next week
[Music]
you forgot
perfectly